do you think it's okay to riot because  he he did specifically say riot so i'm  talking about looting in the stores it  works for friends okay so that's that's  how you you feel like it's okay as long  as it  i mean  if no one here's the thing  um  if no one is listening to you either way  not saying that it's right because it's  not me to say that it's right i mean i  wouldn't want someone destroying my  stuff um  but in this sense like most of the time  and i'm not justifying it but most of  the time these places have insurance for  one and two if you're not listening like  the point is to make a statement  so if you're not hearing anything until  i have to make the biggest statement  that i can make